the pain is underway in Colorado to make
it the first state to ban sales of
smartphones for children a proposed
ballot initiative would make it illegal
for stores to sell smartphones to kids
under 13 or two adults who intend to
give the phones to preteens vladimir
duthiers of our streaming network cbsn
is here with the reaction Vlad good
morning good morning cell phones have
become an important way for many parents
to communicate with their children and
keep track of their whereabouts but
backers of this new initiative say a
change is needed for those who worry all
the screen time is hurting our kids
they're always in it and it's hard to
it's hard to get them to focus and get
their attention
that's why melanie davidson a working
mom in Denver okay you two it's time to
read restricts the amount of time her
two kids spend on their phones it's up
to myself and my husband to help make
sure to pull him out of that every once
in a while sort of to to parent and
police that to some degree dr. Tim
Farnham says he's trying to help I'm
with a group were trying to get a about
initiative he's drumming up support
through his organization parents against
underage smartphones for a proposal to
outlaw sales of smartphones for children
under 13 stores would have to ask about
the age of the intended user and could
face fines for multiple violations we
hear it from early age oh I want a
smartphone I don't a smartphone that's
all the kids want you know they don't
want anything else and now you can say
well you know sorry I can't get to one
until you're 13 in a 2015 survey
nineteen percent of adults set it's
appropriate to buy smartphones for kids
under 13 60 minutes recently spoke to a
former Google product manager who
described how designers create phones
and apps to get people hooked do you
think parents understand the
complexities of what their kids are
dealing with when they're dealing with
their their phone dealing with apps and
social media no and I think this is
really important because there's a
narrative that oh I guess they're just
doing this like we used to gossip on the
phone but what this misses is that your
telephone in the 1970s didn't have a
thousand engineers on the other side of
the telephone who are redesigning it to
work with other telephones and then
updating the way your telephone worked
every day
to be more and more persuasive what
we're doing to kids is not right we're
just we're abandoning kids to technology
and it's doing them a lot of harm
but farnum's proposed banned faces
bipartisan opposition a Democratic state
lawmaker called it the wrong solution to
a serious problem while a Republican
suggested it's the work of those who sit
around all day dreaming up ways to
control your life
Melanie Davidson says it's not the
answer for her children I'm all for
policy as a tool and as a tool for
change but at rule like this no law like
this is is an overreach of government's
role in our lives supporters still have
to collect almost 100,000 signatures to
get it on next year's ballot the
proposal would continue to allow sales
of basic cell phones for kids just not
smartphones with all the games in the
apps in a statement the trade group
representing Wireless company says the
wireless industry provides a number of
tools to help parents make informed
choices and manage their children's
usage number of parents I've spoken to
have said look just don't buy a cell
phone for your kids right I say let the
parents decide or you could also buy a
phone and just have it do certain things
right because I think for safety it's
very important but not set up the phone
they can only dial mom dial grandmother
dial work the safety part of it is huge
why I think it might be a good idea for
a younger age but my right parents -
sigh yeah alright glad thank you very
much